another
computer vision study group session
um this time about masked autoencoders
are scalable vision learners so it's
the name of the paper
quite long
but yeah it's quite an interesting paper
it's
written by the facebook a research team
there's some
some popular names on there some well
known like kyming here of course ross
gershig
who
was mainly involved in mask rcnn
[Music]
so
yeah
let's
first start with a little intro
a little backstory so to say
and
we're here in
ml city so it was another day at the
office in emerald city for harvey
right you can see him sitting here or
standing whatever he's doing at his desk
in the office
and he just finished creating a nice new
space and was ready for his lunch in the
park
so he went out into the park he was
looking forward to a nice sandwich out
on a sunny summer day
but he soon realized that it was getting
way too hot
so
let's say 38 degrees celsius that's
quite hot
in germany at least and
i don't know what is important right
but you can figure it out yourself i
guess um
so it was so hard that he decided ah you
know what i'm going to have a nice beach
vacation
so he went and oh yeah he had heard
about this nice place called neural
network island
where the machine learning folks go with
their image pads to have a good time
and actually about this image here
this neural network items i didn't paint
it myself maybe you see it down here the
signature it was painted by daldi too
because yeah i was just looking for
neural network island uh and google
image search it didn't really give me
anything and then i was like okay
let's try dolly and i really liked what
it came up with so that that's a newer
network island now right
you've got trees you've got
[Music]
neurons connections
a lot of beach
and that's where haki is going now
so when he came to the beach
he was extremely disappointed because it
was just packed with images and he had
no place
and he wondered why they were all
hanging around at this one beach and
then he saw a sign and the sign says
google with training today bring your
image for free tpu credits
right so you see with up here observing
all the images that people bring
actually it's all image net images
and as when how you know ah of course
they're giving away free tpu credits and
all the machine learning people on
vacation just brought their images to
the beach to get their free tpu credits
but luckily hagi got a tip from a local
about another nearby beach
and when he got there he was quite
relieved because there were way less
images
just six really here right now
but
something was strange about them right
they look
a bit strange they look just fragmented
and then he saw a sign
again
which reads fair my training today so my
this is how i pronounce it it's like
mask auto encoders right i will always
say my probably
and
uh they advertise it with bring your
image for free instagram followers right
because it's facebook stuff
but of course i mean machine learning
folks is way more interested in tpu
credits and instagram followers so not
as many people showed up
as for the google bit training
but that was just fine for haki
and
he even saw a boost that was offering
free decoder classes so he didn't know
what it was but well he got some and put
them on and he was amazed because with
the decoder classes actually he managed
to see the images clearly
amazing right
so with this new decoder classes haki
spent a nice day at the beach
and in the afternoon there was a
classification competition between the
vanilla vid that that's how we call the
google the vanilla
and my
really so hockey was sure that maya had
no chance because oh my just saw way
less images
and it was a close result but in the end
my result and my
surprise tuggy and even managed to
outperform the width
so mai was a winner right
and that
[Music]
is
the first intro story
um that i had a lot of fun creating
again
and now we can jump into the actual
paper
um with some knowledge you already
gained now
so
again that's the first page of the paper
right
i already said something
so it was released end of last year
actually so it's not that old or at
least that version version three is from
end of last year
um
yeah
and what is it all about these mask
outer encoders what
are they doing there and why can they
perform image classification
better on
less images than wit actually right
and for that let's first look at this
vanilla bit from google
so it was published in 2020
and was like the real first successful
vision transformer probably most of you
know it and
the biggest problem really at that point
was that they need a huge data set for
good results so to outperform
convolutional neural networks they just
needed
a big big data set so they used like an
internal 300 million something
uh data set
with which they managed to outperform it
but uh yeah
with smaller data sets it just didn't
work and what are they actually doing so
they're
just inspired by uh transformers for
natural language processing and they say
okay let's create some tokens by
actually chopping up our image into
patches
and then we have in this example nine
patches we feed them to linear
projection layer then we get
some
n-dimensional
vector
and that's
our token actually so we put some
position embeddings in front or just add
them to them and then we put them all
into a transformer encoder so the
encoder looks just like this over here
right you get patches you've got your
layer norm the multi-edition and a layer
norm then an mlp and then you just
stack a lot of these blocks actually so
they have different sizes of this bit
and
yeah in the end there's an mlp head that
is using this classification token here
and then can classify whatever is in the
image
okay so that's the vanilla
now the masked outer encoders so first
to say it's it's not really a new vision
transformer model but it's a framework
for effectively training as existing bit
like transformers
so you can basically plug in anything
that is really like like this vanilla
bit that has the same structure
and it works in a self-supervised way so
maybe you know moco would
be it dino or cinema
they're all
supervised frameworks or self-supervised
not supervised but self-supervised
frameworks or methods to
train
vision transformers
um
yeah
but let's take a step back and look at
auto encoders actually so other encoders
are nothing new right
probably a lot of you have heard about
them um just
a real quick intro to them so everyone
knows
the so the the main structure in outer
encoders really is that you have an
encoder that takes this input and image
and then from that image
it somehow creates a latent
representation
and this daytime representation is then
again fed to a decoder which then has a
task to reconstruct the image from the
beginning right
let me just turn my image into some
vectors and then try to
unravel over of that again and get this
image again that i put it
so it's good for self-supervised
learning right because
you always have like a direct connection
and you don't need any labels for the
images
and there's another glass of auto
encoders it's called denoising auto
encoders
and yeah now there's some noise here in
input image and then the task is
actually the same
now it's just
to reduce the noise and create actually
the original image so you would actually
compare the output to the original image
and then
have the
loss between these two images
but this outer encoders is
nothing too fancy i would say
now let's look at the mask outer encoder
architecture
you also see like using encoder right
and there's a decoder and there's some
stuff in between and there's an image
that goes in an image that comes out
now
the difference is
that the image is in patches like we saw
in the vid example right we chop the
input image up and then we mask
a lot of these patches
and we actually feed in
the patches that are not masked right so
the original patches we feed them to the
encoder the encoder comes up with some
representation
some vectors
and
then
we add the mask tokens back in actually
with the position embedding so at the
right positions
and then we feed all of that this whole
mask and unmask patches to the decoder
then the decoder then has a task to
reconstruct all the patches
and actually give us
the target image so the image that we
first
or the original image without any
masking that we put in
so that's that's like yeah really the
basic idea of mask outdoor encoders and
how that actually works
in more detail
we're going to see now
so first we start with the masking of
course where we create patches from an
image for example here in our image we
have four by four
patches or 16 patches in total
um and we get the precision embeddings
then we random shuffle all patches
i didn't visualize that because i was
too lazy to chop it all up
and then
they really just mask the last x percent
of patches right so they really just say
like okay we've got our random shuffled
list of patches now or indeed patch
indices actually and then we just take
whatever percentage we want to use and
um one surprising thing in this paper
actually is that they say the higher the
rate of mask images are masked patches
and the better it works actually so up
to a point of 75
masked patches which you can see here
for example
okay i will just uh
repeat the question for the record
because i think your voice is not
recorded so the question is like how
different is this mask outer encoders to
denoising auto encoders
and yeah yeah i had the same question
actually and in the paper they say like
yeah it is uh like a sub type of
denoising outer encoders we are using
but it differs in some aspects
but they don't really say which aspects
they just say like oh yeah it's just
different in some aspects and
um
yeah yeah maybe you could really see it
like that so it's like
the noising plus bird and just the whole
thing for for images
so i think i'm not that familiar with
denoising outer encoders in themselves i
have to say so i
don't know much about them
um that's why it's a bit hard for me to
like draw the direct comparison
um but yeah probably it's just really
this um advanced
uh yeah advancement made with all the
transformers structure and the patches
and then you
yeah have just built like
training in a way
so i suppose that's probably the
difference
okay
and
cool and i will go on um
where was i yeah so they really masked
me a lot
of patches and
yeah then they've got this masked image
for example here so you barely see
yeah just anything from the kite so it's
just really just a bit here but there
there's some sky
um
and then they go and yeah take these
unmask
patches or these four patches and feed
them in
to the encoder then the encoder really
basically is a bit so they really just
use a bit
of just any architecture could be a bit
big a bit large they even use a bit huge
and
this vid
just produces
the latent representation right so one
thing they do is they add an extra layer
normalization after do it
um right here
that is something i don't know that yeah
apparently was beneficial for them in
their experiments it's extra layer
normalization but in the end so in this
example you would feed your four patches
and your position embeddings to the bit
and you get out your four
tokens
so your vectors or whatever you want to
call them
and
the next step already is the decoder and
for the decoder as i said we add in
all the the mask patches again
right so it's basically just
patches
without any real information
but of course they have to be trainable
in a way so i saw one implementation
where it just used like a uniform
random distribution and then just fill
the patches with it
and they have the same size of course as
the unmasked patches or the vectors from
the unmasked patches
and they put it all in the right order
right with position embeddings they put
it
like it should be
and then they put it in a decoder and
now we know the decoder is supposed to
come up with the image again right
yeah i think it's
so you can see it right yeah yeah
probably that's one of the main
differences really to like auto encoders
it just work with one image right
because here you have all these these
patches and the tokens in the end
uh instead of this this one big image
that you try to
uh yeah do
all
as a whole
um yeah
so probably yeah
that's yeah that is one of the
differences so now now we found one of
the differences between uh
mask outer encoder and the denoising
auto encoder
and yeah the representation in between
i mean what's really great about auto
encoders in general is that
the
encoder and decoder
don't need to be the same architecture
or anything right so the decoder can
really
be a different
of course well it still has like this um
bit like block here right but it doesn't
need to have the same amount of blocks
or anything and that's what they are
experimenting with quite a bit in the
paper so they say okay if you just use
way smaller decoders in the encoder
then we can
let's just save a lot of time
in computation and
for the training
and we will later see like um what uh
their success rate there was
but yeah in general that's like a
beneficial uh attribute of auto encoders
that this encoder and decoder
are in a way
decoupled and yeah just the decoder just
needs to be able to really take in the
output of the encoder but what decoder
does after that is just
up to the decoder really
okay
uh more questions
here
no
okay so let's move on
to reconstruction actually because now
let's say okay we have our image here in
the back that's actually one of the the
real reconstruction images from the mask
auto encoder right you see it is a bit
blurry and everything so it's just
it's not ideal but
apparently good enough
and so let's see now we've got our
output here we've got our original here
right and
um for the reconstruction loss
we now only really look at the the mask
patches actually
so we we ignored the original patches
completely right
we really just um take all these mask
things and then we compare it we
calculate
calculate a mean squared error
between these patches and that's our
loss
basically for the training
that we then use to optimize
and uh yeah get to our results
so yeah it's really also interesting
that they yeah
say like oh it's
way better when we really just look at
the stuff
um
that is completely made up basically
right because these masked patches it
didn't really know anything about them
so the decoder had to do all the work
and trying to figure out what it looks
like
and um you can see it's not really like
fine structures it comes up with right
it's more like these
bigger areas
and i think again that's one point where
transformers are useful
because like transformers are not
looking at that much detail especially
the bit transformer i mean they're more
fine-grained vision transformers that
you'll get more details but this vanilla
is not looking at like details but more
big areas for classification
and in this case it's really helpful
because we don't have to find great
details from the reconstruction image
and yeah
so how do we actually do the
classification right so
let's say you've trained your mask outer
encoder now
and yeah you've got your
pipeline right here so it's quite easy
actually you just
throw away the decoder so everything you
could have learned is that
not important anymore we just care about
the encoder and uh
how it learned the latent representation
and you put on a classification head
like we saw actually in the original
vanilla bit and then you get your
classification probabilities out
and yeah the really good thing about it
is that
for example the implementation at
hugging phase you can just train the
mask outer encoder one which is way
faster than the vanilla with one and
then you can use the weights of the mask
outer and cola and plug them into the
vanilla fit
model and it just works
um so which is a great way when you have
a lot of images that you want to train
the vid on or yeah you just want faster
training you can use the mask auto
encoder
and then
yeah use the bit model
anyway to
classify
okay
are you a bit quiet
yes i can hear you
now it's good now now it's good
yeah that's true and i think one one
main difference to like yeah
i could
imagine that there's like this maybe
just pre-training with a jigsaw
style even for convolutional nets but um
even here we have the position
embeddings right which are i think quite
important actually because we always
know
at which
place
in the image these patches are
and i think that's actually essential
knowledge in in this case
that it's not all shuffled around but
that we exactly know okay this patch
should go here and this patch should go
there
and
yeah
so
well
but anyway thank you for that
yeah i think we're what you're going for
yeah yeah yeah that's really i just like
this uncertain oil this unknown and you
try to figure out okay this is late and
it works best to solve this
uh yeah puzzle
written
i go on and
okay
so actually so what's most amazing for
me in this approach is really that you
can mask like 75 of the image and
yeah
the mask auto encoder is able to come up
with a
reconstruction that is good enough for
classification actually so i wondered
okay what's like
what's it like for us humans right so it
took some of the images
um
from their paper and maybe you can all
have a look like okay right here it's
simple right we all know it's really
colorful it's uh apparently some kind of
bird feathers so that's parrots right
yeah it is perfect
and
the next one might be a bit more
difficult
so
let's go from a human perspective right
we see aya there's some
some green here so probably this is some
forest or anything it's a crown and
there's a cycle and
ah apparently some some human uh what's
he doing there i don't know maybe soon
the wheelie or something but
so actually it's a guy on the unicycles
um
yeah
but still i mean we could see that it's
like the forest and yeah the crown and
something with the cycle right
so
then i saw some black and white images
actually and like ah that looks way more
difficult
and
i don't know if it's just for us humans
or also for the machines and that that
would be interesting actually one of my
questions to the people from the pay
would be like
did they experiment with the with the
color
color schemes actually because i mean
for us humans when it's black and white
we don't have these colors anymore to uh
orientate ourselves right
so we see a bit in here so this
structure okay
well i i already know what it is um i
don't know about you but it is a steam
train actually
so but it's way harder to figure out
when you don't have like the blue sky or
green
green trees or anything at least for me
and
the fourth example that was some people
like okay what if i would just see this
this stuff here i would okay
could be some some clouds or something
could also be steam or whatever
and
then maybe some crown but this one here
yeah so
it is actually a cayenne skateboard and
a half pipe but when we look at the
reconstruction we also see okay it was a
really hard example
and actually the the outer encoder fails
to reconstruct most of the upper body
and everything
because yeah it's just this huge patch
missing here right
so um yeah
some examples work better in some
verse just as far as humans i guess
okay what's the next one ah yeah now we
get to look at the performance because
they of course they also reported some
stuff about their performance
right and um well they use two methods
linear probing and fine-tuning um just
probably again most people know but just
so everyone's on the same page so linear
probing is when you have your neural
network like you have a lot of layers
that align you've got your output layer
and you just
freeze the weights
in these first layers and you just
basically have your
fully connected
uh last layer that you train
the rest just stays the same and fine
tuning or like like a full fine tuning
would be
you just yeah train the whole network
again and you can also do partial fine
tuning right where you just freeze some
layers and you
just leave some layers for training
for the
for the final linear programming linear
probing is basically all except for this
one right for fine tuning
they're mostly doing full fine tuning
for the experiments they have one
uh uh
one figure where they say like ir when
we do just like partial fine tuning
that's our that's our results but for
most of the experiments i really do the
whole the full fine tuning actually
yeah
um
yeah so let's look at the performance
first right so apparently i already
mentioned some other
self-supervised methods like dyno moco
and bait
so we see that
with the different vid
size
models it's a bit big large huge
and then there's huge with the bigger
image
input image size
and we can see that uh of course the
mask of the encoders are better
than the rest as i probably wouldn't
really
report it
and yeah but we see it's not that far
actually especially for the bit big it's
uh 0.4 points better than uh moco and
speed
and yeah here you see the so the bit
performance without
the supervised self-supervised
training so that's basically supervised
and their own implementation and they
are using the imagenet 1k dataset
for their self-supervised
experiments and yeah you can see that
the best result is really the biggest
fit model and a bigger image size so
here they are using 224 i think so i
think it's a half of what they then used
here
and yeah
so in general that's that's like
compared to the other ones and some more
ablation studies they did was for
example the mask sampling right so they
they are now using the random sampling
as i said they're just randomly
shuffling the indices and then just
throw away
or just decide which to mask from this
randomly shuffled array basically
but they also experiment with block
masking so where they just like do these
huge blocks
and also with quit masking
but they are definitely saying okay best
results are with random shuffling and
random masking
even though the crit is a and also
this block is
not that far away i would say but still
the random shuffling and masking is best
yeah and that's about the masking ratio
as i said they are using something like
75 percent so here in this access you
can see the masking ratio and here you
see the accuracy again for fine tuning
first here
so for fine tuning you see there is a
big step between 30 and 40. after 40
it's like uh okay it's
about the same
so when you fine tune the whole thing
apparently it's not that important if
it's 40 or 75 percent
if you're doing general probing so if
you're freezing most of the layers
then it is important because then you
see quite yeah quite a steep
curve actually
and then 75 was a the sweet spot for
them that's why they just use it in the
end
and i have the decoder size as i said
the decoder can be
of a size
to be experimented with right
and again you see for the fine tuning
the number of blocks in the decoder it's
actually not that important you can even
just use one block in the decoder
when you do a whole fine tuning in order
to get really good results
for a linear probing again it is
important or more important because you
get the best results
um when you have eight blocks that's why
they use eight blocks in the end in
their implementation
um
in depth and in this they have like 512
dimensional vectors
that i decided to use again for fine
tuning it's often the case in the paper
that for fine tuning you're like okay
well you can also use small stuff you
can use big stuff it doesn't make a big
difference it's mostly the linear
probing that really got them got them to
their parameters that they're using in
the end
and yeah augmentation is also
interesting because like
data augmentation so stuff like cropping
the image flipping the image changing
the color right color jittering
it's actually quite important for most
self-supervised tasks
but here in the mask outer encoders
actually say like oh it's not actually
not that important even if they use no
augmentation okay it is worse than the
rest but um especially the color
jittering is actually degrading the the
uh score
so um yeah it's interesting because
this
augmentation
uh is really mostly one thing
we have to augment our images and self
supervised learning so it learns better
um but here probably because of this
masking and this yeah already leaving
out a lot of
image information it is not
that important
oh decoder size again okay sorry
oh yeah and they also did some
experiments on object detection and
segmentation with the cocoa right so
they
they were using like a rc and mask rcnn
with
space line and then they compared
again with the other ones
and yeah they were slightly better or on
par with paid
for object detection and segmentation on
the cocoa data
and yeah for semantic segmentation they
used
ade 20k somatic segmentation data set
with uber net
and again they were better
than the rest
so you can also do that
and that's that for the the paper itself
thank you to this point i do have some
some code you can look at
because uh yeah
the mask auto encoder is available
in the hugging phase
uh transformers package of course and
this official implementation you can
check out i mean the slides will be
uploaded in the github repository
for
community events later
and yeah there's this phase with my
that's what it called so especially
basically the bit mask auto encoder
right
and there's really nice keras io example
done by uh
and actually when i went when i had some
questions from the paper i often looked
at this ksio example um
to just see how it could be implemented
what they're doing there
to understand some stuff and yeah
i will quickly jump into this
with my unhugging face
so
yeah
as we see overview right there is some
information here you can see there's um
the bitmai config
where you
can configure
your whole
stuff whatever you need like patch size
image size number of channels
decoder hidden size decoder intermediate
size
then there's actual model
and then there's a vid mile for
pre-training which might be the most
important if you want to really use it
because this bitmap for pre-training is
uh yeah the stuff
that you can train your your own images
uh control your own images for training
and then in the end get the weights that
you can use um with a normal
fit
i will show you in a second yes made a
notebook about it
and then there's the tens of low
versions
of it as well i think also contributed
by uh sayak
uh yeah really nice uh let's quickly
look at the notebook from yields
again here
this one
yeah that's the one
so you can see that here
you get a feature extractor right just
the normal bit feature extractors with
what you can use and
yeah you can use it from pre-trained
facebook with my base
that's a good
model to play around with actually from
the facebook
people and
yeah then when you have your your model
like here
you can just create it well here and
this mainly uses it to
visualize
the images or the masking and
reconstruction
[Music]
and then here you can see actually so
when you just really want to classify
you just load the bit for image
classification from pre-trained and you
actually
use the same
model name you can use any mask outer
encoder model name that is
trained with it and just plug it into
the david for image classification class
and then you can go on a classifier
yeah and there's a lot of warnings
actually and yes it says like yeah
because you're not using decoder weights
it will give you a lot of warnings so um
don't be scared by that
and that's how it's supposed to be
apparently
and
yes
okay to this point
are there any questions now
um
now it's really just
the mean squared error loss they are
doing um
a normalization on the pixels but that's
really all they're doing in like the
original
implementation so from the reconstructed
image
they're basically taking yeah they're
normalizing
the patches
and then they're really computing just
the mean squared error loss between the
reconstructed and
the original
um
[Music]
yeah
even though i saw in the official
implementation
there's a notebook somewhere
that they also have one checkpoint where
they're using
um
wait
gun loss it's it's called i think
yeah i'm out with extra gun loss so so
maybe that's the direction you mean
yeah i haven't looked into that but you
can see that reconstruction is better
here actually than before right
so they also have that even though they
don't report it in the paper
but in the official implementation you
can find it
okay
if there are no more questions
then
yeah no worries
it was a pleasure
and yeah if you have any more questions
feel free to to write me or write in the
chat i think the general event chat room
in discord right
yeah
so thank you for attending
and have a good day
you